giza dream
sheets okay first time playing
you played d4 in the last game let's
give e4 a whirl
e4 e5
okay
let's go knight c3
so
i'm thinking about
the earlier blitz game
who will get this uh
who will activate the rooks first
is what's cross in my mind
all right bishop c6
c5 i can't get this in
d4
but we could go one
let's do it
okay
now in that blitz game i played earlier
in the stream i was pointing
out after the fact the computer said you
could have you could have played f4
but that was in a different scenario
where the bishop wasn't already on this
diagonal and h6 was played
non-developing move
so i'm thinking a bit differently about
playing f4 right here
so for example f4 there's chop chop and
then queen h4
which turns out to be a pretty hungry
and invasive piece
i don't want to lose a pawn
you go for a quick mate on f7
i don't see any real benefit in that i
don't think black is inconvenienced
here queen f6 there knight f3
maybe i have that
but there's 97 black is on move in that
position
securing their queen post on f6
all right let's let's look at more uh
non-beginnerish moves than going to h5
uh what's crossing my mind probably that
one
candidate move bishop e6
let's begin with bishop to e6 bishop e3
oh
can i name a square
let's see how black reacts to that
first
okay so just like in the blitz game
opponent is
not biting
so
let's go with
this one
or
let me let me go with the h3 actually
um
i
should have noticed that
you know if they really want to they
could take and then have my king go
uncastled
uh
i'm not really sweating that
because my king should be pretty healthy
on d2
i'm gonna do similar
we're both uh
keeping the tension between the b's
neither one of us wants to open up the
f-file for the other
so
boom boom check
here
eventually i get a tempo back like a
castle by hand
that kind of stuff
my king is cozy here i don't force
i wouldn't really be foreseeing the
center opening up
[Applause]
it could but
even
you know i'd had i i'd have an extra
pawn around to combat
some stuff in the center i liked the
pawn on e3 controlling a night jump for
one
so we continue
okay 97
flexibility city with the f pawn
cool okay i have to worry about that are
we in a completely symmetrical position
nearly
copycat variation
hmm i mean they're ready to play d5
maybe
maybe i go ahead and chop here land a
check and then play queen h6
would that bother them
they'd have to go queenside then
so chopperoni chopperoni check
block no they don't have to they have to
play this they could play knights knight
to g6
maybe just queen h5
what exactly is she doing i don't know
tightening bishop takes bishop
let's try it
it feels beginner-like
so let's do it
that's that's my final reasoning
before playing that move
just do whatever feels beginner-like to
you
all right
i'm once more down on the clock
they're a tinkering
i don't want to
say what i think black should play here
i'm fearful of
stream snipers
it's a very dangerous thing you have to
pick and choose my moments
you know
is queen gonna make a move is this pawn
gonna make a move
i think uh i think bishop here would be
amazing no they didn't bite
okay i think queen d7 is one of the
better moves
now
big moment
or is it
i tell you what i'm still going to stay
flexible here
i think we might end up both going queen
side
so the primary difference
i'm seeing in the position is the
location of the queens
she's out in about no knight on f6
is giving up this square i'm not really
concerned so much about g6 i improve and
she seems
like she's a stable piece on h6 for at
least a move
and i'm not really
concerned about
my queen getting trapped
okay
oh here's another thing i should have
considered consider this maybe on the
last move
but if i take this bishop you can't take
with the pawn
not winning the bishop the queen or the
knight can recapture
but i still like this idea where i could
uh
exchange my bad for their good and i'm
not helping
them file wise in the process
this is sensitive
but the in-betweener of knight takes is
not working
after king d2 i'll be winning a piece
so chop chop queen side castle i'll want
to defend this
no i don't like that takes takes
queen side castles
there's then g6 kicking my queen from
defending this knight
and then
knight takes knight knight takes knight
queen takes a2 so
also they're ready to uh simply take
here and then go here so i have to have
to do something about that maybe i just
chop here with the bishop
um
yeah
okay
so are they gonna have a space invader
pawn yay or nay
i probably should have thought a little
bit more about my last move oh you know
what i'm seeing here
yeah i have to go i have to go back i
don't want to go to the center
yeah i'm in trouble
i'm going to go on castle now because
after bishop check there's knight d2 or
i don't even i don't even know if i want
to go here nor play c3 after bishop to
a5
maybe i just do a tight walk king f1
king g1 and castle by hand like that but
it's still going to be an inconvenience
for me
so
okay they didn't bite that was that was
some bait i was throwing out some bait
there they didn't they didn't fall for
it
okay i had that square covered
sneaky sneaky
watch out for the sneakiness
who in the chat was maybe believing me
were you a believer to all those
variations i didn't see it initially i
must admit
that queen whenever she has a an eye on
a square seven steps away could be
tricky to see
all right well i'm gonna have to take
some extra care over the dark squares
okay
my queen clearly needs to find a new
home
is h6 a reliable home
you're not gonna hurt me
are you
you're not gonna hurt me
g5 i'm just asking for h6 i'll go to
i'll go to
i'll play h6
this one move later i don't really mind
my queen's also defending the knight but
i'm ready to queenside castle
do i do i want to capture on e6 i still
don't okay i think they're playing this
very well
maybe now i want to take
and then
i don't know gotta go faster though know
that much
i'll go inside
yeah i'll go queenside
how to recapture if they take here
knight is the first one that crossed my
mind but then this knight has an awesome
square f5 oh
maybe i just take and then
claim that my rook is ideally placed on
the d file
and i have to start going into
a faster mode
if bishop takes how am i recapturing i
think i want to take with the pawn i
like having this move for the night
feels like this knight's out of play
even though i'm generating a threat
against d5
um i think i'll be taking with the apon
yeah let's make a quick move
i'll do similar
copycat
when in doubt
more bad advice
uh what i would like to do is establish
a pawn here here and then throw a knight
there
that would be enormous
maybe i still will do what i take with
the knight i don't know
this move has been crossing my mind all
right that one
sneaky man sneaky
all right let's get this moving now
there's a pin actually
okay i think i think i spotted a good
move here i think
i think i am liking
my move knight f4 you can't take in this
direction
bishop could back off but if it backs
off there's still a pin present it's
unprotected on this post
this square f7
back about a minute and a half
forget forget about this f3 move
anymore this this position is
going to open up so the e file i should
be occupying the e file soon
this guy right here is strictly defender
i i see that
bishop be different if this was a hole
you know some night getting in there and
then it's it's supported by a bishop but
for right now i just see this guy is
mr defender for the king very good
defender but
yeah okay so they
there i could even think about pushing
chop away
i'll go with this though
chop chop chop chop knight here they get
this pawn
let's get here first open file
maybe looking at this
pawn takes this kind of is a little
fancy but again i don't want knight f5
hitting so easily
all right
down to the wire
this one will be over in five minutes or
so
good struggle
imbalance space for black bishop pear
for black
i don't think it's a bishop pair that is
thriving but okay still
this is
the stuff that's grabbing my attention i
could have also considered queen g7 why
not strike at the bishop directly give
some direction move forward a little bit
i don't know how much of an
inconvenience it would be
i should have given more thought
to putting pressure on that bishop okay
so now am i not just winning a pawn
chop here with the knight
or the pawn
i'm gonna go with the pawn let's open
the file
and then jump here like i was pointing
out
the night this night getting
here
with this
this the these corresponding squares
the bishop is is felt here i
didn't know that that was a move
all right
maybe a little annoying i think
let's go with this
now
i'm going to take with this pawn
i want to i have the flight square now
and i'm anticipating queens off in a
very active rook on the seventh rank so
i take the queen first
and then take this excellent bishop
and then activate my rook
so my rooks are playing
blacks aren't only one open file and i
have it under control
i should have maybe started with the
knight to c4
yeah maybe that would have been better
knight c4
okay
oh no you know what's better than that
this move
stops this bishop
okay keep the open file i think it said
the rook back bishop c5 and then i had a
decision if i want to stay on the
seventh franc
there's gonna be problems there so i'm
gonna i'm gonna go more invasive now i
start to think about this and also a
beautiful square on c4 and if they try a
flight square here this with this a pawn
on v6 is a serious serious thorn
things are things are looking pretty
sweet here active versus passive rook is
what this one is
coming down to
and
actually more than that because i think
i have the superior minor piece
okay so where else is this guy gonna go
this is a nice cozy square
let's get him there
king steps over i get the b-pawn it's
very very very tough to
do anything about this rook um
is this most precise maybe maybe my king
coming over here is best
i'm gonna
i'm gonna go in this direction so that i
could abandon the e file and my rook
could
start being a hungry piece
maybe my king
somehow gets here
can make this pawn flinch so we're gonna
go here now these guys are frozen rook
can't move pawn can't move pawn can't
move
this move is only helping me
my king's eyes light up my knight's eyes
would light up to maybe getting to e4
they're kind of tied down they don't
have really any moves
so i guess
i want to be careful about moving there
um
hmm
let's try that first
i don't know the king steps over
yeah what am i really accomplishing
now let's go here
i really don't want to give check
or i really don't want to go to the
e-file
because then there's this this check and
then that
the rook is activated and defending
everything if i allow their rook to get
to the seventh
yeah then we want to be careful about
that
if the king goes here then i could go
here because the check cannot follow
with that
all right i think in the end it's going
to be a time winner
and now i could go here
could have also gone here that would
have been super annoying my rook remains
a pest
bishop might be dead
i think the bishop's dead
here here everything's falling should be
completely winning very good game
tight resistance there for quite a bit
you